("Django Bluegrass")
- Toaster pastries.
I mean, do you toast them
or do you just eat them like that?
- Never toasted a pastry in my life.
- It looks like bread and jam with icing.
- It's a proud sponsor
of the American Olympics.
I cannot see Michael Phelps winning
gold medals eating this one.
- Oh God, that's so sweet.
This is the cause for obesity in America.
- That is so sweet.
- This is what I've been waiting for.
- Taste the explosion.
What, it's gonna blast in my mouth?
- I love how they sound.
I really wanna eat them.
- One, two, three, go.
- Woah.
- Oh my God.
- Ew, it kinda tastes
like toothpaste a bit.
- My mouth is having a battle with itself
and there's just like
rockets flying all over.
- Although I really can't
make out any flavor,
but I'm just enjoying the experience of
stuff popping in my mouth.
- Yeah, OK, I do like this.
This is awesome.
- The explosion was boom, boom, boom.
- Yeah. (makes explosion sound)
It's like ding ling ling ling ling ling.
Ding ling ling ling ling ling.
- Twinkies. What kind of name is Twinkies?
- I heard about this on "Zombieland".
- Individually wrapped cakes.
It makes me feel important falsely.
- It looks very creamy.
- That's a lot of cream, man.
- That is a lot of cream.
- Mawa cake is like Twinkies, but better,
made by local bakeries in India.
- They're good, man.
- Yeah, I like it, man.
- Nice, but very sweet.
- I thought it'd be horrible,
and it would be very heavy,
and dense, and disgusting,
but it's damn tasty.
Butterfinger. Crispity,
crunchity, peanut buttery.
- Oh wow.
- I didn't expect it to be so hard inside.
- This is really crunchy.
- Crispity and crunchity.
- These are good.
- Yeah.
- I thought it would be like a 5-Star,
which we have here in India.
- This is just (mumbling)
when you bite into it.
And I would definitely have this
over most Indian chocolates.
- I'm really excited about this
because I loved "Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory"
as a kid.
- This is like Playdoh.
- OK, yeah, it is really chewy.
- This is gonna take awhile.
- It really feels like everything clay.
- This is gonna probably
take me the entire
cricket match to eat.
- I'm getting this really sour taste,
but it's also a nice sour taste.
- Thumbs up for American processed foods.
- Oh wait.
I think one of the earlier
Pop Rocks just popped again.
- Do you guys have this every day?
- Yeah, because if you
guys have this every day,
I really can't imagine how your lifestyles
must be like.
- I'm just imagining a bunch of really
hyperactive kids, man.
What I really liked though
was those Pop Rocks,
which were really, I mean,
they just blew my mind,
apart from my mouth.